[Music]
welcome
folks my name is will welcome to our
session today
talking about the experience going from
stanford
to africa we have some really
cool panelists that i'm really excited
um to be sharing space with today
so once again my name is will i'm one of
the admission officers here at the
stanford graduate school of
business and today we're going to be
talking about what your journey could
look like
from stanford gsb to africa to a
career that is fulfilling something you
are excited by
something that you feel that you are
able to make an
impact and that you're excited to do
every day
so to walk us through we'll do some
brief introductions
from our panelists from there i have
some prepared
questions and then we'll go to q a and
so as you're all getting comfortable in
that q a box
that's the place you can go ahead and
start asking questions
right now if you'd like i'll do my best
to incorporate them through the process
and in the end dedicated just to your
questions and we'll be here together for
about 55 minutes
so just to give you a brief overview
from stanford you can literally
go anywhere part of the experience is
how can we provide
both the fundamental skills as well as
those soft skills the things that you
need to do to adapt
so that you can be successful and thrive
regardless of where you find yourself
both geographically industry-wise
maybe you're creating a new industry
yourself maybe you have that vision
we have 60 alumni clubs from around the
world over 30 000
alumni as well so wherever you might be
interested in
there is going to be an alumnus or
alumni there or
someone that they might know so as you
think about you know the gsb
community you are also the part of their
extended network
and stanford university being able to
say i am a graduate of stanford
university
also allows you to connect with folks
from the engineering school
public policy so many different fields
of expertise
that can help you along the way to
continue growing as a professional
so over 50 clubs and organizations at
the gsb
as well one here that might be of
particular interest to many of you might
be the africa business club
and we are grace to have multiple
leadership
members from that organization as well
as from the africa business
forum one of our great events on campus
that we could
we'll be able to talk about in a little
bit so
to kick us off let's start we'll go left
to right
if we could start with zifo are you
there um probably just
settling back in um so we have one
panelist who'll be
hopefully joining us shortly but until
then maybe zueli can you get us started
um tell us a little bit about yourself
and what you're doing now
cool hi everyone my name is zueli i
am originally from south africa and so
and i'm business i live here right now
so prior to gsb
i worked in consulting consumer and
telco
and currently i'm running a startup in
the clean tech space
in south africa trying to see if we can
make the process of getting solar
storage easy for residential customers
and super excited to be here and then
did you know that you wanted to um uh
work in africa when you came to the gsb
i i wasn't 100 sure right so i knew that
my long-term plan was to be back in the
continent and i only graduated last year
but what's swayed the decision for me
was basically a class project in startup
garage
where we basically started doing user
interviews exploring a little bit more
and that's where the concept of import
homes came and when it became clear that
that's something that energized me and
excited me
even though there's an industry i didn't
know i was then pretty sold that i was
going back
to africa immediately we'll definitely
talk about startup garage more
later on eugene can you
please please introduce yourself and
tell us a little bit about what you're
doing these days
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us today i'm eugene
kenyon and currently dialing in from
nairobi kenya
i worked in international development
and financial services um
investing in emerging markets before the
gsb and i'm currently working in
energy and infrastructure investing
focused in africa
and i knew from when i was joining
business school that i wanted to come
back to the continent
nice and then zeufo welcome you are
i have to say having worked with my
previous colleagues
salva you are legendary so glad that
you're able to join us today
can you please uh introduce yourself a
little bit about what you're doing these
days
yes yes sure hi and
thank you so much for having me i'm so
glad i could join the the conversation
it was important for me to be here even
though my schedule
i'm sure you know but um yeah i'm a
business leader i'm a business woman so
i'm involved in many things but
i guess primarily i run my own business
i've got a team and we actually work
with leadership teams of multinationals
that are operating uh within africa
particularly south africa
um and really helping them with business
recovery strategy
you know growth uh all kinds of topics
around sustainability
i also invest in early stage startups so
i've invested in a couple of uh
gsb founded uh businesses
uh and stuff and just and involved in
many things but i'm so glad to be in
this panel
and happy to answer your question that i
hadn't just uh asked the others around
the part to to be it's a stanford in
africa i'm very similar to in eugene my
heart
i believe africa's best talent you know
you know this is home so i i went to
stanford knowing very well that
my goal is to have an impact on the
world but emerging from the african
continent and really showing the world
you know what africa has to offer i do
that in my day to day that's why my
reputation follows me
and i've seen many of our alumni do the
same so very excited to be seeing
everyone
again on this channel nice and wanna
welcome
i'm glad so happy you're able to join us
if you could do a
brief introduction and tell us a little
bit about what you're doing these days
uh thanks sorry i'm late i had a call
that overran
it was important it was a deal that i'm
going to do so and i'm also having an
exit
conversation there's a lot happening i'm
hiring a ceo it's really crazy on my end
here
i just came back from a kenya trip i
drove over so just a quick introduction
um yeah um iguana alley and i've
basically from tanzania where i now live
i i i had an early career in the u in
the uk
in the air aerospace um military flight
testing
some commercial and then i moved over to
to the west coast
with gsb 2007 5007 uh i think
my class is often hired as being very
entrepreneurial
uh in a number of different ways i mean
my roommate
um uh founded
d-lite design sam goldman which is a
solar company that scaled in
in africa quite a bit but also ned tozen
was um his own in my class
um and more recently clubhouse was
founded by one of my classmates uh
paul davidson uh and the list is long
there's a lot of others and
uh in our class so i'll cover a few
entrepreneur class but i did go to
microsoft after the credit for the gst
for a few years
then went back came back to the area i
couldn't deal with the seattle rain
came back to bay area did vc
for a little bit in the early stage
accelerator space um
around 2010 2012 and then moved back
to africa 2012 to start savannah fund
and so we're coming to the end of our
first fund um so obviously 2012 meaning
that
you know for a 10-year fund 2022 would
be
next year right and so that's why i'm
scrambling to get some exits
for that first one but our second fund
has now been live
we had our first first close or second
fund uh three months ago which was um
led by ifc the world bank and i believe
we're the first
seed fund uh in south south africa
they've backed
they've done egypt they've done middle
east um
south africa but not uh sub-saharan
africa
um so yeah so on the second one now and
yeah i've been doing
capital now for almost 10 years now for
the continent
as i mentioned i used to be in kenya but
i moved to tanzania four years ago so
i'm living in northern tanzania
uh near kilimanjaro near um uh some of
the great parks
uh like sergey gorongo crater and the
reason i moved here is because i can
also
drive to nairobi so as i mentioned i
drove back on tuesday morning after
spending two weeks in
uh in in kenya uh i always say that i
have one food in kenya one foot in
tanzania
i i i couldn't get vaccinated into
tanzania so i drove
over to kenya to get vaccinated as an
example then i kicked off my trip into
uh
into the rest of uh uh uh investor so i
was announcing for a whole week so
that's a
quick intro on myself i'm happy to talk
more and discuss my experience
yeah and then did you know that you
wanted to come back to africa after
graduation or
how was that yes i mean part of it is
that tanzanians are quite well known
for going home we've been lucky that
tanzania has had no
like sort of you know uh administration
that kind of or like you know the usual
aspects of africa that have
often scared away folks from returning
tanzania's been fairly peaceful we did
have a small blip maybe with our
last president magufuli who sadly passed
away allegedly of covet
in march and now we have the first
female president in in the region
uh and she turned the ship around so you
know we
you know i may have left tanzania um
or may have been planned to leave
tanzania if you had the same president
for another four years but
she's pro-business uh samia uh and so
yeah like i think
that backdrop always meant that
tanzanians are you know pretty happy to
stay
to come back um but i would say that
yeah like um
you know my dad also got a family
influence a big deal and my dad always
said don't come home without a plan
and so i couldn't come back to tanzania
or africa without a
for example the gsb it was better that i
worked a little bit
you know what how did i say that
microsoft and did vc it was only once
once i had a fund raise
to move back to africa that that was
like okay bless this move because
you've come back with a real plan right
and so that was a huge influence
the timing of i guess bc industry kind
of early days
plus my dad being comfortable that
i wouldn't come back and be a bum
because i could because that was
basically my dad's
fear is that a lot of people in tanzania
come back home but they just kind of
you know don't really do much uh and so
my you know that that was definitely a
big factor
and of course you know i'm sure the
others have said this but the students
make a massive impact
has been really really important for me
um
and yeah like i didn't just move back to
tanzania kenya but i've gotten to invest
in
nigeria in uganda ghana
south africa i'm there regularly
mozambique i was there
just uh two three months ago ethiopia is
now emerging and that investment there
so the fact that vc gives me this you
know the idea to come back and do an
africa fund has always fascinated me and
the deeper you go
the more you see right and there's more
out there right there's still drc
there's a lot of countries that i'm
really interested to do more and
you know it's it's uh really doing you
know
i guess if i was just moving back to say
kenya or just tanzania by myself i'm not
really doing anything much beyond that i
probably wouldn't have done it
but i know that this is a global game uh
as well as regional in africa so that
you know but i still get to go back to
the bay area right
i'm planning my next trip in the fall
where obviously government's hopefully
subsiding but yeah i actually travel a
lot to the us because because i have lps
there
so i you know um i don't miss the high
rents in the bay area
so i'm not very happy where i am uh and
also i travel to
hong kong and also europe as part of my
because i have lps in those markets
so i'm actually to be honest the biggest
thing about you know moving back was
i'm actually more global as a result
than if i stayed in the bay area i think
yeah or um
so i feel like i've really utilized um
you know my my um uh
education and my quest to go global
by doing africa vc so that was the right
opportunity for me
default speaking of going global i know
you
are also very well traveled can you
tell me a little bit about how that has
impacted the way you view
kind of leadership development and kind
of
like your profession at in africa
yes well most definitely most definitely
i've had the privilege
of having traveled now 37 countries 37.
exactly my last trip was just before
the first knockdown is south africa in
february and it hits us in march so
i'm very looking forward to traveling
again more soon uh but i'll be honest
like i mean i come from very
impoverished uh background right
and for someone like me traveling was
not something that was ever at home
right
in terms of where i come from and my
community etc and
um and for me having an opportunity to
to really go to stanford right and just
spend time
with people from all over the world
right was really a big it was a big
wake-up call for me
but not just that i mean just that
opportunity of being there it's so
encouraged that you you actually
be part of the world's oyster and i made
the most of this right i mean when i was
at stanford
i mean i did my exchange program into
china
i uh i did another another program to
russia
like a global study trip um i you know
went with classmates or colleagues did
another program brazil
all over the world right so i mean those
are opportunities that i was able to get
that really opened my eyes and really
opened my mind in so many ways and it
also encouraged me like as much as i'm
passionate and i always have been
passionate about the african continent
it really spurred me to make the
decision to actually move to spain
you know learn spanish from scratch
you know and work for the world's
biggest retail group i was in an
international director role
and i ended up traveling by the time i
came back to the african continent that
worked across
you know six different continents i'm
never going to go to antarctica right
but that opportunity i'm still advocate
at heart um
that opportunity opened my mind you know
because i started realizing that
you know there's different ways of
leading right and right now the premise
of how we lead and the whole education
system to be honest right
and even the workplace et cetera it's
you know it's influenced by one
systems of thinking one system of
thought right and what i really
appreciated
about being at stanford is that it
really opened our minds a lot
uh to to the fact that there's more to
the world right and there's also a lot
more places to learn from
you know so we learned from that whether
it's the first world developing world
and all kinds of for the world so then
when you're talking about leadership
i think for me having come back to the
african continent i've learned and i've
realized right i mean i mentioned that i
spend my days
a lot with multinationals you know the
ceos of these big giants rights helping
them make these businesses sustainable
and one of the things that i encourage
them is um it's really important to need
from
what is authentic to you as a leader
right
because you cannot be someone else you
can try fits into someone else's script
right
that's not who you are that's not your
call and one of the things about us
being from the african continent as some
of the people are listening is that
there's a certain ethos of leadership
that is part of our dna from so many
generations
that's what the world needs right now so
how do we leverage that right for all of
us
as other leaders in different parts of
the world do the same because then
what ends up happening is the world
benefits from that right and that's what
i
enable leaders to do even the leaders
that i work with that are not
from south africa or from different
parts of the african continent and
they're coming here to have impact and
drive businesses
and i say to them there's been there's a
premise you know how do you think about
bringing what you know but how do you
think about honoring
the best of what comes from where you
are here basically but if you ask me
whether it's self-awareness
right or that level of um you know that
ability to challenge yourself and say
but what is authentic and what is real
to you as a leader
it really comes from how i was
challenged you know in my own journey in
the mba
right as much as i was happy with my
progress and my achievements and i was
keen to learn more
there i was really challenged to really
grow and ask myself what kind of leader
am i
and then what does that look like when
you when you then go out to the world
right which is what i did
and also what i loved and i reflect back
fondly on is that
i was never encouraged to follow any
script you know i was really encouraged
i feel like for me whenever i reflect
about my journey with stanford
they encouraged me to be the best
version of myself that i could be
whatever that is right and stuff and so
today yes i've always been
entrepreneurial i mean since i was five
years old i was running businesses
you know for survival for sustenance
then fun then
you know everything and then yesterday i
have businesses
but um it's it's something that i'm
realizing now what kind of entrepreneur
i am right and stuff and then also
having the opportunity to create
jobs and really create opportunities for
for young people to work with think
about it in what space do you get an
opportunity to get access
to leaders of multinationals right and
stuff and so being able to create that
opportunity for for young talent is
something for me that's
been important and then that's been
really really critical and i think the
last
the last one thing that i'll also
mention is that one of the benefits of
also
just seeing different parts of the world
right is i think it really helped me
[Music]
appreciate the strengths right
appreciate and honor the strengths
of uh my journey who i come from because
sometimes
people tell half the story you know we
talk about the things they're struggling
so i'm get them out but there's lessons
from the difficulty and there's lessons
from that growth
and let's be honest right look at what
happened with 2020
it put trauma in all of us everybody
everybody and we had to ask ourselves
where have you faced difficulty where
have you faced struggles
and guess what we know the script we
have the answer just because of the
legacy of where we come from as a
continent as a people
this is the time that the world needs to
learn from us and i'm very passionate
about just making sure that
that's taken to the rest of the world
right as much as possible
yeah and i love the way you
talk about being empowered to embrace
kind of
what is there and share it and like find
that strength
in that place of who you are so that's
amazing
um kind of bridging from something you
said before this is for israeli and
eugene
um she was talking about like
challenging
the way that you see yourself
challenging the way you see
the world kind of on the threshold of
your gsb
experience as you're returning to the
continent can you talk
a little bit about maybe an experience
or class that has challenged you in that
way i know there's a couple questions
in the q and a box about were there any
classes
um in particular what were some of the
it things
that helped you see kind of yourself in
in new ways
um so maybe zoe lee can start with you
and then eugene will follow with you
sure no thanks for the question um so
for me i think a lot of it was
trying to explore what it meant very
experientially
to be an entrepreneur and start a
business right so
and in ways that again so my prior
background was working in consulting
even in industry
consumer and telecoms i'd always started
things like organizations in high
schools
small little businesses but i would have
never used the term entrepreneur
to define myself um at all and i'm not
i'm not
too kind of sure why but i think the
idea of then
now having basically uninhibited
what does it look like to start
something from absolutely nothing
so concepts interviews trying to
interview users in south africa in the
valley and recruits people
and put things together made me realize
how much of those skills
i might have learned even though i would
have fully appreciated it and therefore
how much
of that can be a very big part of like
the career
and choices that i've chosen and i think
that it would have been very hard for me
to make that transition
outside of that so just both the classes
but also the idea that
there's this big theme at gsp
around doing something that really
matters to you
but also challenging yourself to say
what does it look like when you start
things from zero to one
right so my prior experience in
consulting you like helping big
companies grow
and there's a certain skill and thinking
set here
but that idea of like training across
kind of people management
marketing functional area zero to one
for me was very kind of
impactful and there was both in the
classes but also even the experiences
interacting challenging classmates kind
of you know the kinds of speakers that
come to school
and that had a very big impact very
direct in that place it made me choose
a different career choice immediately
it's part of doing it during
pandemic but that was like a big impact
for me nice
and then gene how about yourself like
what are some of the ways that the gsb
has helped you challenge kind of the way
you see yourself in the world
thank you very much will i think i'll
speak to two things i think the first
the first
uh like i think really transformative
thing that that
that happened to me at the gsb was i i
learned how to embrace failure
because i think i think one of the
things the mba does the program really
stretches you
i think beyond your imagination and and
there's so many opportunities
in an mba program you think you can do
everything so i remember i
i really loaded up my summer you know
last summer i wanted to do you know two
three internships and you know travel
the while and go explore the startup
space in nigeria
and i i remember you know my last
assignment i just wasn't able to
complete it i was just too stretched
and and i didn't know what to do and i
just reached out to to
sort of the stanford c team that was
that was you know working on that
internship program and i told them you
know what i don't think i'll be able to
complete my
my tasks in this last assignment and i
think for me the reaction
that the school you know because i
initially thought i'm gonna get you know
punished for this i committed to
something that i can't complete
but but i think the way the school
reacted to that and even
put me in touch with an alumni and you
know got a sort of a lot of help around
that in terms of accepting
when you feel you've taken on too much
and accepting failure and actually
learning from it and i remember one
thing
this particular alarm told me and he's
actually one of big bc investors on the
continent
he told me he doesn't invest in anyone
who's never made a mistake
and that is like mistakes are part of
learning and that's just not something i
hadn't you know you come you come to gsb
maybe you're a bit of a
perfectionist you're used to getting
everything right and and i think for me
this was this was
you know one time that i realized i
can't always be right and i can't always
do everything by myself and i should be
open to
reaching out for help and i'd say the
other thing is is taking a bit more risk
uh so going to business school you know
initially imagine i want to go to b
school and then come back and work for
one of the biggest investors
you know in the african continent the
more established names and then you go
to stanford and you you're exposed to
sort of
both types of businesses and you realize
perhaps it's a lot more exciting to work
with
sort of smaller newer you know
businesses that are
still experimenting with their business
model and so that's how ended up
deciding to go to africa 50 which is
barely four years old and just try to
figure out their strategy around the
continent
and testing a lot of new things so it
feels even though i'm working for a big
file it still feels
uh very startup-ish and i think that's
that's something i picked at the gsb
and and i eventually how i see that
pointing out is that i'd probably be
are trying to do a funding in a couple
of years down the line
nice and then eugene you mentioned
stanford seed can you tell us a little
bit more about
that group please yeah stanford state
for me was actually one of the reasons i
was very keen about going to stanford
especially because i knew i want to come
back to the continent right after
uh so this is an entrepreneurship
initiative that supports
uh close to a thousand businesses now in
africa
and and so so it takes african
entrepreneurs through
an entrepreneurship training program to
help them scale scale their businesses
and and they do allow stanford students
both from the business school as well as
other schools to intern at stanford city
and stanford pretty much meets the cost
so it's actually a really good way for
you to
to try and learn about a part of the
continent you haven't been because many
of us
you know grow up you know you know in
south africa and that's all you know
about africa maybe you know your
neighboring countries but maybe you've
never
worked or lived in north africa and
stanford it gives you that opportunity
as an mba student
i bought you know your first of your
second summers you could actually
do two different internships in
different parts of africa
and and and get to sort of increase your
knowledge and network about the
continent so for me that was one of the
best things about stanford for an
african student and also a very strong
partner for the
for the africa for the africa business
club in terms of funding you know
helping out with events and networks
so it really really makes experience for
africa a bit more wholesome
african business club you just said it
it is
selfishly one of my favorite groups like
they have such
amazing people um and just
we were on a panel recently and they
were talking about
how like this just the celebration of
what it meant to be
african at the gsb at stanford and just
the way the energy
of all the panelists lit up was amazing
and i know we have
folks here who are involved in the club
um
i'll open this up to whoever likes like
would someone like to talk a little bit
about
africa business club what it does uh
maybe any experiences that like just
really spoke to you from it
yeah i can uh because i mean now i'm
seeing how dated i am but
just to give you context africa african
students in the gst wasn't that high
when i was there
right and like i see some questions here
where people asking what is the stanford
alumni network done for you etc
there wasn't a big you know to be honest
that was a big decision i had to make um
do i go to the west coast or something
some of the east coast schools around
and who's got the
better africa network i got to when i
went to stanford
and i was joining the clubs i joined the
uh black business school association as
well as the abc
but they were not but abc wasn't that
big it was kind of seen as quite
but then i've seen it over the years
particularly after i left
so this is kind of the back question of
what has the gst done for me after i've
left you know i almost feel like i've
got as much out of it in the last
particularly
five or six years than i did even you
know because of course
when you graduate from the gsp those
first early years depends what you're
doing
but i was always at microsoft and you
know trying to find my fee i wasn't even
going back to africa yet
you know yeah i'm not going back to
africa as i mentioned but um
looking back on it one of the things
that has happened is i've had two gsb
case studies um done on our african
businesses
golex or bid finance in the in the
bitcoin crypto space
that case that was written up in 2014
right
so i know crypto is hot now or kind of
was hot last year or this year
but it was also hot in the previous wave
2014-15
so i had a gsp case and it was the first
crypto case
in the gsp and it was also one of the
first africa startup cases
right um and then more recently i think
2000
aerobotics a drone company and as you
know i used to work in aerospace
from a bio from a buyer so um it was an
ag
tech drone company both african cases
but also
um uh there was a class that's become
more popular now i don't know how
how it is both um you know in the recent
years but
steve jozinski and a few other
professors are doing emerging markets
entrepreneurship class
features these case studies and there
was an emerging markets entrepreneurship
class when i was there but i've gone to
co-teach those classes
right a guest lecture which i love with
my own case studies of course
there's two i mentioned which is that
will also led to a pattern of students
who are intern for me so for example
lauren dunford
she interned for me and then also a
company called the saturn linux
that just raised the series a last last
month right and then also i have steve
as my board
um so he's on my ic sorry investment
committee so i've kind of woven
so it's kind of gst is kind of woven
into what i do
um in my fund in that i have students
that intern for me
and i've done well started companies
that i funded and i've got professors
who are also invited ac most likely
invested in my company you know my fund
and
just kind of like so i can't help but go
back to campus because i just get all
this feedback of talent
um but yeah like i know that the africa
business forum has become very big it
didn't exist
when i was there right so to to be
honest i'm kind of jealous with some of
the uh
of the students who have been there
later or had more africa but when i was
but when i was at gsp i would you know
it was not that big and i was running
through
hbs and wharton conferences but i'm very
excited to hear
to see that not only is the abc grown
and there's a conference
african-american forum that's becoming
that i've been twice
but also there's more students i mean
there's africa fellowship i believe that
it's still there i believe um uh a
tanzanian the second tanzanian after me
to go to the jesus benjamin fernandez
was the first one to get that i think
i'm tanzania so i've encouraged the more
popular africans coming to gsb
but yeah like just kind of do something
gets around how i've used dsp to help
help me um really enjoy my work
and one other thing i wanted to mention
is that um what unexpected aspect of my
kind of jsp
that i didn't realize would help me was
my favorite class
was actually the non-profits class run
by bill meeham at the time
he's now retired he was an ex mckinsey
consultant and
done a lot of stuff in a non-profit
consulting with mckinsey but he actually
told me yeah he actually
had a really amazing performance class
um
that i didn't think i would use but i'm
using almost every day because i'm a
board chair of
africa's biggest entertainment star um
uh nonprofit
above the kids reaching 17 million uh
africans
and i and i literally am using
everything i learned from that class
daily as a board chair obviously
broadcast nonprofit is a big deal
right for example i'm not hiring a ceo
compensating the ceo and
you know uh i'm referring back to my
notes about
how um you know the non-profit
competition
is very different from the for-profit
side of things obviously vc by day
but by night i'm also this non-profit a
board member uh
and so i'm learning a lot from that um
yeah so that was probably one like my
favorite class and it's been very useful
other fun fact bill meeham told me not
to do vc
he said when you he said when you go
back to africa and don't do this
i'm going to work i didn't take his
advice on that one
but i'm still using his knowledge and
experience from non-profits in africa so
this doesn't mean everything you learn
from the gsp you can directly apply or
the advice you're going to get from
that directly makes sense because of
course back then there wasn't african bc
right there was that emerging rockets
wasn't there
bc was just a you know silicon valley
us maybe china and india and europe
but obviously fast forward to today you
know 15 years later almost
you know he sees africa is growing
really amazingly there's a lot of uh
startup activity i mean
some of the others have mentioned that
they've been involved in the sector you
know
but it's gonna start to mature more and
more so bill was wrong
for his time but he was definitely has
some timeless gems from this
non-profit class that i'm still using
today nice
and then d4 i know you had a leadership
position
as well in africa business club so i'll
i'll turn to you in a second there was
one question as
we're talking about fellowships there
was a question earlier in the q a box
about funding
the gsb and the education and so we have
evolved over time so now we practice a
need-based financial aid process
so basically the philosophy is we're
taking a look at things like
prior your income assets so that we can
make sure that the folks who need the
most support are getting the most
financial aid
so that they can come to this the gsb
and make this a reality
this year we also launched a new program
called the bold fellows fund
and so this is in recognition that for
many people you're not the only one
going through this journey
you might be supporting family or there
might be other expenses
there might be a dedication to
diversifying the conversations
and the dialogue that you're with that
you're surrounded by
and so there's an additional fund of
money that you can apply for
um to help close that gap even further
between financial aid
and the cost of attendance so lots of
different ways that we're looking to
support our students
um and there's also a bunch of different
and creative ways once you're here
um we have a financial aid office that
works very closely
with our students so if you have
questions once you're here um you can
always set up appointments with them as
a student
and you know we will do our best to
figure out what could be
a life path that makes the most sense to
get you through this gsb
experience and so from that segway
default i'm going to turn it back to you
as
one of our um kind of former leaders of
the abc can you tell us a little bit
about that experience
yes yes almost definitely most
definitely um you can see leadership is
something that's very close to my heart
so i was one of the leaders
of the african business club community i
was also in the international community
and a few other things right just
because i think it's important the world
is your oyster
but from an africa business club
perspective um i think there's a few
things right for me
it was definitely an opportunity one on
the campus just that intimacy that
you're able to have right
with your colleagues also with people
it's not just i think also we need to
open our minds right
when you talk about africa business club
people that are interested in that it's
not just people coming from
africa right it's actually people even
from other parts of the world
but that are really passionate about
building relationships and connections
with people that
uh are from that continent or might have
a passion for doing business in africa
but the bigger sweet benefits that no
one didn't mention here is because
um you know when when you then uh get to
be in a leadership position i guess with
the africa business club
you get to choose whichever african
leader or any african interested leader
you want to advise
right and they come right it means the
sample class is very small by design
it's very intimate right
and so what you end up doing is you
invite a president
you know and he comes and he has lunch
with us right these are the things that
happened that stanford and you're like
what is the way of getting access to
someone like this but it happens so i
just used it an opportunity to to
network and build relationships with
you know president influential
presidents influential business leaders
because they come you know they also
appreciate the opportunity of spending
time with us when we're at stanford
i also want to encourage people to think
beyond
your class so for example i mentioned
earlier that one of my passions
um is you know they say you should never
make these kinds of decisions uh like
best in early stage
businesses because with the chances of
failure uh are quite high right
but it's something i'm passionate about
so i do it as a as a way to give back
it's not at all my primary business
but if i then look back and i think wait
what are some of the investments that
i've made over the years right
one of them is a gsb alumni from my
class 2014 and you know he's starting
an aviation business i mean one of the
first and cutting edge airlines in pan
africa right
and they launching this year their first
airplane and i've invested in him for
so many years now i think six seven
years and then another one is another
uh again a nigerian alumni doing a
fintech startup right now driving it
from the us
another one is another gsb alumni also a
half african half american and uh he's
actually built a business that is the
first uh you know quality education
for the middle class um and he's rolling
this across africa
and i also invested in someone like him
early in the day and he's from
i mean he used to be my mentor you know
when i was with behind the ears right
and then post stanford you know when i
heard his vision i went and i supported
him
so that what i was trying to say is that
you know the the network that you get
right so when you're thinking about you
know that african business network
it goes across it actually goes across
generations it also goes across
countries right and even recently like
i've looked into like
doing seed investments you know so some
stanford people in china
but it's not the same when i'm you know
the passion that comes i'm like wait
i get to see the impact much closer to
me at home right and even zarya's early
i've known him from idiots it's
also one of my mentees so very proud of
him when he uh you know and he was he's
been in at stanford
but uh also just you know what he's
building i just think there's all those
opportunities that
those amazing people we get to spend
time with each other get to know each
other much better
and also the networks even some people
who prefer clients to my business right
it will be people from um stanford okay
from different parts of
different generations of stanford some
of them have never even met
they just know of me or have heard of me
and then they refer clients to my
organization so i just think that the
network
that you get with the africa business
connect uh goes beyond that
now actually i mentioned earlier that
one of the programs that was really
influential for me when i was at
stanford was the global experiences
program right
i mean it opened my mind right and i
spent time overseas in
immersing myself so i have now went and
created that opportunity there's
literally a current stanford student
that's been selected to come work for my
organization this this literally the
month yeah
because we're just so busy and we're
hiring so aggressively we're looking for
talent
but i just thought let me open the
opportunity and he applied it so he'll
be
helping us and you know he's canadian by
background you know speak spanish
imagine that kind of opportunity that
he's now having access to
you know maybe even learning about
business in africa you know so
that's what it is for me it's it goes it
we get global
right and then it's also up to us what
you want to do with those opportunities
uh depending on what your aspirations
are
in life right and also i want to i also
want to say i think i think in my head
the processing speed as i'm talking but
just listen to our conversations i can
hear also people are thinking wait this
one is an entrepreneur
sunset entrepreneur wait this one is in
vc right
all options are available for you beyond
that because one of the things also when
i was going into stanford i was like
wait is it only for entrepreneurs right
yes i'm an entrepreneur at heart but
i never was like yes that's my ultimate
so but i i challenged myself when i went
there and i said no
which part is it gonna be and that what
i loved is that
when we then met different business
leaders like at the beginning it was a
lot of entrepreneurs and like the
impressive ones you know the ones you
read about in the
papers all the time they were like
coming and sitting with you in the class
and telling you their cases
but as more as mo and them came i
started finding what i call
i see myself as a business leader right
as much as i'm passionate about
entrepreneurship i'm a business leader
and i started seeing myself seeing
people like me we're like business
thinkers like in terms of how they make
their choices how they build
their entities and i started seeing that
no no entrepreneurship is not
one way right like the book of you know
where you have the trash
uh under the you know it's like you're
the one who takes out the trash there's
that storyline right it's just you and
it's the best
there's many ways of building it and
stuff right from from the garage to
you know a much more structured
environment which i've tried to do you
know even from the first day it's always
been a very very
classic you know fundamentals of
business design but obviously
growing aggressively right especially
living in a pandemic
and just being accelerated with the
growth you start seeing so many things
uh breaking
all right and uh so eugene you touched
me and you said you know
what i think wasn't wanna was like i go
to the books right
and the notes and the notes uh you know
i keep saying to myself
go to the notes because the stuff is
there right
so the classes that stand out for me
managing
growing enterprises i keep planning to
go to the notes but everything i learned
from this so relevant
uh and stuff there was also a class that
changed my life
uh you know they say when you're at
stanford there's actually two but they
say when you're at stanford
there's one usually there's just that
one class that gets to you and i know
there's touchy-feely right
i'm sure someone will get to that that
was a transformative experience
from an interpersonal uh growth
perspective but definitely there was one
with job
uh bob jaws i believe he was it was
issues in leadership
and it was two weeks it was only two
weeks that it was one of the hardest
classes to get into
in two weeks my life was transformed in
two weeks
but it's because of how he just that
ability like he cared so much about
helping us grow as his leaders i mean he
laid a big bang
in like australia i had worked he'd been
there for former dean at stanford
he'd achieved so much in his life but
the fact that he was passionate about
developing us
and just that ability of really helping
us all introspect and
and he said look i've read and i know
the best insights on leadership
i've narrowed it down to the ones that i
think are transformative from generation
to generation
that material for me was absolutely
priceless right
because then it's allowed me to then
have a lens on leadership that is more
universal
but also it's empowered me right the
leaders that i work with think about it
uh well but people were leading
businesses today i'm in my early 30s
right
they are in the north of uh your
multinationals i'm not going to offend
anyone but in the north of
whether it's late 40s or 50s i mean
that's the people leading corporations
today
but i have the confidence and the and
the power to actually
be able to help them multiply the bottom
line and they come back here and yeah
why is that why is that it's because i
was really really pushed challenged
myself to say
bring something that's different to this
world that doesn't exist yet right
and it's there on campus you know the
placard right well
it's written down campus right dedicated
to the things that haven't happened yet
and the people who are bowed to dream
them up and imagine
looking at that every day every day and
it eventually hit me you know years
after i left stanford
and i genuinely feel that everything
that i do is i'm literally
you know bringing up the things that
haven't happened yet and i'm one of the
people
who's crazy enough to dream them up
right
that's that's the difference after this
don't be surprised if i go out to make a
t-shirt that says go to the notes
you know just as a reminder and go to
the notes y'all have it already
oh i eugene enjoyed it i saw the two of
you smile when
people mention interpersonal dynamics um
anybody
did either of you take that course any
thoughts on
i don't think yeah so as i took school
interpersonal dynamics so touchy feely
and for context for folks who might not
know
this is very strange class when twice a
week
you have six hours unstructured with 12
basically random classes and two
facilitators
and you guys are just left there to just
be and to deal and to interact
and it's just very interesting because
inevitably it
kind of brings to the fore the things
that are most important
in both understanding yourself what
motivates you
but also how you interact with different
people and therefore how to then
kind of influence them but not from a
hey i am the leader i'm going from a to
b
just truly listening and understanding
and also having a very deep sense of
wait here's the set of experiences i've
had
this is how they shape how i see things
here's how other people see things and
how to balance that off right
and that for me was kind of super super
impactful and felt like i learned
a lot from that and then also became a
much stronger version
of myself from that song yeah
and so bridging from that maybe kind of
connecting to a question that isabelle
has asked i know we've been trying to
weave in some of the
parts of questions throughout um but
something between
um as you're challenging yourself and as
you're making that transition
and return or have been working on the
continent for a while
like how have some of these realizations
helped you
work through like challenges that maybe
you hadn't anticipated before
so can you tell us think about like some
of that connection like how did it
prepare you for that
maybe i'll give okay maybe kind of give
one right so so one
was around again for me kind of a lot
more my sample experience is about being
entrepreneurial
but there's a bunch of things i've never
done before right i never tried to hire
people
and i never experienced the almost
pain joy scariness of talking to someone
being excited and then seeing that drop
off
and still feel like things must go on
and i was trying to do that trying to
you know recruit people for a project in
south africa find exciting
energy fun exciting but trying to find
people who are dedicated and want to
work with that kind of deeply
and even that you know just the
realization and learning
from trying to recruit you know
classmates from across
the street from other kind of schools or
like in your class and trying to
see what that fit looks like has been so
valuable but also knowing when it works
and when it doesn't work
but still having the confidence to say i
need to take this from a to b to c
to d i'll take that in any case has been
very very useful for me and then
transitioning then pretending to be
someone's boss
and try to almost hire them and that's
been kind of one thing that's been just
like
a very big thing that like i would have
never thought about
but the idea of having to recruit
teammates and trying to kind of put
together resources
and trying to get that across has been
very kind of valuable with that
the other part i think is something that
usually has touched and you know there's
some experience with banner as well
where
a lot of kind of actually see some
student entrepreneurs a lot of gsb
lecturers have been
investors or advisors etc but then the
comfort and confidence of saying you
know so there was a class where
someone's like okay
now you're doing energy from south
africa i want to just like email elon
musk i'm like
what do you mean like that's not a thing
like this
audacity and that daring is just saying
kind of why wouldn't you
right and that like you've proven
yourself enough to be able to have those
conversations
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
work that has been also super kind of
impactful
and has been critical in this kind of
journey that i've been through
um right now possible yep so coming back
to that the things that haven't happened
yet and the people who are about to
dream them up
kind of spirit and mentality i know
we're closing
we're starting to close in on time this
has flown by
so as we start to wrap up and maybe each
one of us
each one of you can take a turn at this
question is as we
start to wrap this session um any tips
words of wisdom or advice for folks
out there who might be considering
um kind of a future going from stanford
to the gsb whether that's application
as a leader like what is like a piece of
advice that maybe you would have given
yourself
um kind of a younger you and that
you know that other folks can learn from
along the way so we'll take a moment
think about that and then whoever wants
to jump in can get us started
i think i'm happy i'm happy to go fast
on this one uh so i think
you know when i remember my time doing
the application i think
almost at no particular point did i ever
think i had a chance of getting in
so i think i was just in kai because i
think when you speak to a lot of people
trying to apply you know people tend to
focus a lot on oh i didn't
i didn't get a perfect gpa in undergrad
i didn't come from this industry
maybe i'm a bit too old and people tend
to focus a lot on why they think they
wouldn't get in
i think the reality is that they they
need a single applicant who's going to
keep all the boxes right
um so i think uh focus on the things
you're strong at and the things you can
actually change so if
if you didn't have a very good and a
great gpa you know try get a good score
scored hdmi
if if you know you you're not very
confident you know about you know your
ability to write a greater essay then
maybe get
amazing recommenders and spend time
building your relationship with your
commenter so that they get to know you
beyond just you know you as an employee
or a student
so i didn't focus i'd say focus on the
things you could actually improve
and and don't don't don't waste so much
time
you know lamenting about the things you
don't think you're very good at because
i think at the end of the day
once you go to school you realize you
know everyone had that dent in the
application that they thought is not
it is going to stop them from getting in
but they eventually did
i can go next yeah
[Music]
this may be i'm not quite sure how uh
this next class will come in but uh
assuming
everything's back to normal with covet
et cetera i mean don't forget to go
across the street when you go to
stanford like
when you go there you should you know
it's easy to be on campus all the time
but
you know silicon valley is an amazing
place i mean i i
i the first year i focus very hard on
the clubs and their academics
i know things have changed is how they
do the the curriculum now but i spent a
lot of my second year going off campus
meeting i mean at the time when i was
there facebook was very new
right um you know a lot of my classmates
got hired
into facebook um there was a lot of uh
you know entrepreneurship activity and i
don't know that's gonna change
valley is it's to still be the center i
want to finish it for a while
so you know go across the street not
reaching the campus but into palo alto
mountain view et cetera
san francisco i wish i did more of that
but i but i think when i was there i did
enough of it
that it helped build some connections uh
that would be very valuable beyond
uh just the campus um yeah so i think
that's something that i wish
you know all students to realize when
they go there it's like you need to
really
you know take advantage of the silicon
valley it's an amazing place
it's very magical place i think they'll
continue to be so take advantage of that
yeah and i'm happy to to to add from my
side
i think um i'll be filtered in what i
say because i also sit at the interview
final round panel
so we're not allowed to give any advice
and this is not advised
but i think the big thing for me is um
this is probably one of the most
transformative experiences
in most people's lives right and i
didn't believe it when they told me
before i thought they were making it up
and i felt that way since even though
i've had so many amazing things happen
to my life since then
so one of the things that really helped
me back then is that when i started
applying i started asking people to read
the essays
they kept saying no put the efforts and
i put
months of effort months of effort into
it and so i really encourage people to
say if this is one of the big
opportunities in your life right you
might want to put in
efforts so that you make your best bets
because
you know it's thousands and thousands of
people applying but there's a spot for
you but you need to make that effort and
you really need to do it and i'm really
glad i made that effort and yes i got
into a number of
mba programs but stanford for me was
always the first choice and i'm so glad
that i made that effort to just uh apply
right and put in the
the efforts as much as possible and i
think that's important i also wanted to
talk to what um one i was talking about
which is
he was also talking about networking
across right i wanted to also mention
that
just going across the building right
stanford the business school
it's the the rest of the school is there
right
and for me growing as a leader stanford
gave me an option to
what is this thing you choose what you
want to do with your experience
for me growing as a leader is not just
about the education or the business
classes so by the time
i left i'd done a class at the medical
school right
literally when i was with doctors during
my mba i did a class at the acting
school so i literally had to physically
move my body i did a class at the music
school where i literally had to
you know stretch my vocals and uh on the
sports academy side and took some
programs there all within
my mba and some of them might be
negotiated to get credits for them
so i just think it's so much that you
can do across uh beyond the business
school that i really encourage people to
think of the experience as this is an
opportunity to immerse myself
in an environment that has silicon
valley right next door
right oh it has a palo alto and then
there's also the california parts did i
mention the weather
all right and then uh beyond that though
just the people
at stanford absolutely amazing and um
yeah so that's what i encourage people
to do work out in your application
and then prepare yourself and just to
have fun and meet some amazing people
yeah and to that point first week of
august we are hosting an application
week
where i'll be hosting a series of events
to help you understand our application
process and
help you put your best foot forward and
zoilie go ahead and take us home
so i think for me it's kind of like
registered point that zipper made right
so earlier around being your most
authentic
self so someone said if you're if you
have a comfortable with more than five
people in the world reading your essays
it's probably not personal enough
and kind of the motivation is that like
you know there's a really high chance
like there's a really kind of no kind of
accident rate so if people are trying to
fill that class with the perfect
candidate then probably do that 10 times
over
what really will distinguish you is
saying what
really reflecting on yourself and
digging deep in what's most important
there
and then tailoring that to be the most
true version of yourself
both when you're at stanford but also
kind of
reflecting honestly while you're kind of
before while you're stanford and
afterwards right
because in the end of the day that's
where the biggest power you have will
have
and then that's also where kind of
fulfillment happens whether or not
it is conventional successful or not if
you feel like you've kind of followed
the part that's
in you and you've used that time to
reflect that's probably the most
important thing for me
at least when you're kind of looking at
the essays and the application process
it all starts with you so
thank you so much to everybody who
joined us thank you to our panelists
until our next time if you haven't done
so already please feel free to jump on
mystanford.nba
with a quick little kind of
questionnaire we'll be able to help
create a dashboard for you
populate some events that might be of
interest and keep you updated and in the
know on what's happening around the gsp
so once again from stanford from all of
our panelists on the continent
thank you so much for spending time with
us today we hope to see you
soon and be safe have a great rest of
your week everyone